well i'm really excited to bring our
next guest to the desk because he spent
the last year
um doing something very special it all
started when he lost his office job last
summer
and days later he created i want to mow
your lawn it's a charity offering free
lawn care
to veterans and seniors in his new
jersey community and that was just the
start of a movement for mowing from one
man and one mower it's grown to guess
what
115 volunteers across 31 states wow
that's a movement
so i saw this story and i literally
can't believe it he's actually here
right now please welcome brian schwartz
[Applause]
how did you turn that into looking
outwards and wanting to take care of
others
i definitely felt like my world was
caving in
and you know i just i went outside to
mow my own lawn uh just to clear my mind
think about life like what's next
and i found it to be just a form of
therapy
um
so i just
packed up my mower into my family jeep
drove around
and um just kept going give social
distant
yard work free of charge
i know
you have been well i think about what
you did which is just
one little thing mowing along but it
started a movement now you've inspired
so many other people and i know you got
one letter in particular from somebody
that meant a lot to you
yeah yeah so um
hearing from all kinds of people over
time um got this letter in the mail from
someone that i don't even know
uh who this person is or what they're
going through like got a little card
that says you make a difference
this is the actual letter the actual
letter
um it says be the reason someone
believes in the goodness of people
and that kind of just like and says you
are the reason sir and so that murdered
me just to keep it going
um i got this t-shirt like made on her
behalf whoever it was and i wear it oh i
love that and her what was her name
her name is salon
um
we actually um
have a follow-up from the letter um
here is the woman who wrote you this
letter her name is sloan
and uh roll the tape take a look right
there
hi brian i'm sloane sheridan thomas i'm
the person who wrote you a note
about i want to mow your lawn your
service that you're providing during
this pandemic and
i was truly inspired and wanted to
appreciate you for that
um i think you're amazing and i'm
also just appreciate how much your
business has grown
since then and thank you for doing all
of this for old people and veterans and
let's stay in touch and become pen pals
that would be great
[Applause]
[Music]
you would yeah
it's like unbelievable
nice to know she is real
put a face to the mysterious angel
unbelievable
she changed the world well i want to
donate five thousand dollars to your mo
that your lawn i want to mow your lawn
i love it and i love you brian schwartz
you're just so amazing thank you so much
just amazing just to be here just
so amazing so thank you everybody go to
the drewberrymart show.com to learn more
about i want to mow your lawn
[Music]